placebos in gaming are real during the
multiplayer beta for 2003's Wolfenstein
enemy territory testers complained that
the Thompson was too overpowered
compared to the axis MP 40 but there is
only one problem they're identical
absolutely the same damage rate of fire
reload speed clip size absolutely the
same despite both guns being carbon
copies of each other the Thompson was
getting significantly more kills why
well the sound the Thompson sounded
Meier than the tinny MP 40 player a it
was Stronger so they had more confidence
and got more kills so the devs had no
choice but to Nerf the sound but this
isn't the only case of a placebo in
gaming no matter how much we explain to
them H they would always complain every
version is a this is worse than the last
version change it change it back one
time I just got so fed up that I would
just artificially subtract people's
pings like by by ne-50 and then a lot of
players like oh my God what did you do
this is incredible